[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Jon: WELCOME TO "THE DAILY
SHOW".
MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WE'RE BACK.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
OUR GUEST TONIGHT OH, SHE PUTS
THE HUFF IN HUFFPO.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON WILL BE OUR
GUEST TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, FOR WEEKS THE BIG
STORY HAS BEEN THE MISSING
MALAYSIA AIRLINES FLIGHT. TODAY
SATELLITE DATA SEEMS TO
HAVE CONFIRMED THE WORST. I
THINK WE ALL FEARED THIS STORY
WOULD END IN TRAGEDY, AND SO
EARLY ON WE TURNED TO THE NEWS
MEDIA FOR A SENSE OF SOBER
CLARITY.
>> AIR TRAFFIC CONTROLLERS IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA HAVE LOST CONTACT
WITH A JUMBO JET CARRYING 239
PEOPLE.
WE'RE OF COURSE DOING ALL
WE CAN TO GET AS MANY DETAILS AS
POSSIBLE FROM OUR SOURCES
AROUND THE REGIONS AND THE
WORLD.
>> Jon: THIS ACCURATE AND
HUMBLE ASSESSMENT FROM CNN UNTIL
THEY REALIZED OH, (bleep) WE
HAVE 23 HOURS AND 59 MINUTES
LEFT TO FILL.
[ LAUGHTER ]
(bleep) IT LET'S GO NUTS.
AND THEY DID.
WITH EVERYTHING IN
THEIR BAG OF TRICKS.
GIANT FLOOR MAPS.
BIG FAKE AIRPLANES.
LITTLE FAKE AIRPLANES.
HOLOGRAPHIC AIRPLANES.
NO AIRPLANE DETAIL LEFT
UNSPOKEN.
>> A PLANE LIKE THIS IS AROUND
61, 62 METERS END TO END.
61-62 SIDE TO SIDE.
>> Jon: YOU ARE TELLING THEM
WHAT A PLANE LOOKS LIKE?
[LAUGHTER]
DID YOU FORGET WHO WATCHES CNN?
YOU COULD TELL 90% OF YOUR
VIEWERS LOOK OUT THE AIRPORT
WINDOW AT THE PLANE THEY ARE
ABOUT TO GET ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT, OF COURSE --
[ APPLAUSE ]
THERE'S A SAYING CNN IS POPULAR
AT AIRPORTS.
[LAUGHTER]
OF COURSE MAN DOES NOT LIVE BY
HOLOGRAM
ALONE. GIVE ME A SIX BOX,
FLANK IT, NOW STUPID ME.
>> PEOPLE ARE ASKING ABOUT BLACK
HOLES AND ON AND ON AND ON AND
ALL OF THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES
NOHA SAYS WHAT ELSE CAN YOU
THINK? BLACK HOLE? BERMUDA
TRIANGLE? AND THEN DEJI SAYS
IT'S JUST LIKE THE MOVIE LOST.
I KNOW IT'S PREPOSTEROUS BUT IS
IT PREPOSTEROUS, DO YOU THINK,
MARY?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jon: DON'T ANSWER, MARY
IT'S A TRAP.
[ LAUGHTER ] SOME SORT OF
WEIRD BERMUDA TRIANGLE
OF LOGIC WHERE QUESTIONS ARE
ANSWERED BEFORE THEY ARE ASKED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> A SMALL BLACK HOLE WOULD SUCK
IN OUR ENTIRE UNIVERSE.
SO WE KNOW IT'S NOT THAT.
THE BERMUDA TRIANGLE IS OFTEN
WEATHER AND LOST IS A TV SHOW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> Jon: WELL --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
-- I KNOW IT'S A TV SHOW BUT IS
IT, MARY?
[LAUGHTER]
LOOK AT ME, MARY.
MARY, LOOK AT ME!
[LAUGHTER]
IS IT?
YOU HAVE TO DRIVE ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE STUDIO, MARY, LEVEL
WITH ME, MARY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WOW, DID THAT LOWER THE BAR,
CNN.
BUT I THINK YOU CAN GO LOWER.
>> INVESTIGATORS SOMETIMES USE
PSYCHICS.
WHY HASN'T ANYONE CONSIDERED THE
SERVICES OF A CREDIBLE PSYCHIC
SPECIALIZING IN MISSING PERSONS?
IT SOUNDS INCREDIBLE BUT THEY
HAVE BEEN USED BEFORE.
>> Jon: YEAH, WHILE WE'RE AT
IT WHY NOT USE THAT OCTOPUS THAT
ALWAYS PREDICTS THE WORLD CUP
VICTOR?
WHY DON'T WE STRAP SOME WINGS TO
WOLF BLITZER AND LET HIM LOOSE
BECAUSE IN ORDER TO CATCH A
PLANE YOU MUST BECOME A PLANE.
[LAUGHTER]
CNN'S MISSING AIRLINE OBSESSION
NOT ONLY DOUBLED THEIR PRIMETIME
RATINGS IT ITSELF BECAME NEWS
BECAUSE THE ONLY THING LESS
LIKELY THAN AN AIRPLANE
DISAPPEARING OUT OF THE SKY
IS CNN'S RATINGS DOUBLING.
>> SPECULATION HAS BEEN
REPLACING HARD FACTS IN NEWS
COVERAGE EARLIER THIS
WEEK CNN ANCHOR DON LEMON
BROUGHT UP THE THEORY SOMETHING
QUOTE SUPERNATURAL
COULD BE AT PLAY.
>> THE NETWORK IS IN DIRE
RATINGS TROUBLE.
THEY GET A PULSE.
OKAY.
SO THE EXECUTIVES ORDER YOU GUYS
HAVE TO DO THIS WALL TO WALL.
>> Jon: YOU BETTER BE CAREFUL
O'REILLY OR FOX'S COVERAGE OF
CNN'S OVER COVERAGE WILL BE
COVERED -- BY CNN. NEWS LOOP!
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF BILL
O'REILLY SPEAKING WAY HE
DID?
>> I THINK HE IS NERVOUS BECAUSE
HE LOST IN THE DEMO THE
YOUNGER VIEWERSHIP THREE NIGHTS
IN A ROW LAST WEEK
AND HE STARTED GETTING NERVOUS.
>> Jon: WE ALL KNOW MOST OF
O'REILLY'S YOUNGER VIEWERS ARE
COMING INTO THE ROOM TO MAKE
SURE THEIR GRANDPARENTS ARE
STILL BREATHING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T --
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I THINK IT DOESN'T COUNT, ONCE
THEY PUT THEIR HAND ON THE
CHEST, DOES THAT COUNT?